>> Tucker: SEEMS LIKE JUST THE
OTHER DAY THAT AMERICA'S
SELF-DESCRIBED MORAL LEADERS
WERE DENOUNCING US FOR PUTTING
OUT THE OBVIOUS.
DEMOCRATS ARE INTENTIONALLY
ACCELERATING DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE
IN THIS COUNTRY FOR POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE AND THEY ARE COUNTING
ON BRAND-NEW VOTERS.
THAT'S WHAT WE SET ON THE SHOW.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER, THEY BECAME
COMPLETELY HYSTERICAL AND SAID
WE WERE ESPOUSING ALONE ON A
RACIST FANTASY.
IN OTHER WORDS, SHUT UP.
AND THEN THIS WEEK, THE NEW
CENSUS NUMBERS CAME OUT AND
HERE'S WHAT THEY SHOW.
THE NUMBER OF THE PROPORTION,
THE ABSOLUTE NUMBERS OF
AMERICANS WHO DESCRIBE
THEMSELVES AS WHITE HAS DROPPED
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
HISTORY AND THE TOTAL DECLINE IS
AROUND 5 MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT IS HUGE.
EXPERTS WHO STUDY DEMOGRAPHICS
FOR A LIVING WERE SHOCKED AND
HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
WHY DID THIS HAPPEN, WHERE DID
ALL THESE PEOPLE GO AND WHY?
THEY ARE AMERICANS, REMEMBER.
AS LEADING DEMOCRATS PUT IT, WHO
CARES?
IF YOU ARE WHITE PEOPLE IN
AMERICA IS A GREAT THING AND WE
SHOULD CELEBRATE.
>> RIGHT NOW, STEPHEN MILLER AND
DONALD TRUMP ARE IN MAR-A-LAGO
AND ARE THROWING UP BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT THE AMERICA THEY WANT TO
SEE.
>> HER NAME IS SUSAN RICE AND
SHE IS ONE OF US AND GUESS WHO
WAS IN A FUNK AT TRUMP OFFICE?
>> Tucker: DID YOU HEAR THAT?
HER NAME IS SUSAN RICE, SHE IS
ONE OF US, MEANING SHE'S
DEMOCRAT, NO, ME AND SHE IS NOT
RIGHT.
IT'S THE NONWHITE PEOPLE DURING
THE EXTINCTION OF WHITE PEOPLE.
IT'S THAT EVIL.
YOU WANTED TO ENCOURAGE
PERMANENT RACIAL DIVISION, THAT
IS EXACTLY HOW YOU WOULD TALK ON
TELEVISION.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMPLETELY OUT
OF CONTROL, THEY ARE DANGEROUS
AND IS NOT JUST CNN, THERE IS NO
MORE DIVISIVE THING YOU COULD
SAY ON TELEVISION.
THERE IS NO WAY YOU COULD MORE
QUICKLY AND MORE PERMANENTLY
WRECK THE COUNTRY THAN TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GLOAT OVER
THE DECLINE OF A RACE.
SERIOUSLY?
IMAGINE ANY OTHER RACE PEOPLE
TALKING LIKE THAT, IT'S NUTS.
BUT AGAIN, MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ARE TALKING THAT WAY OR PRETENDS
TO SERVE IN CONGRESS.
>> LOOK AT WHERE THE POPULATION
IS AND THAT'S HOW WE WIN OR HAVE
TO TRY TO WIN IN THE CENSUS
NUMBERS BECAUSE THE POPULATION
GROWTH HAS BEEN IN THE CITIES
AND IN THE SUBURBS OF MINORITIES
AND THAT'S WHAT GIVES US SOME
LEVERAGE.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
DEMOCRATS WHEN WE HAVE FEWER
WHITE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
CELEBRATING.
SHE JUST SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
YOU SHOULD NEVER SAY ANYTHING
LIKE THAT OUT LOUD, BUT THEY ARE
FOR "THE WASHINGTON POST"
COLUMNIST JENNIFER RUBIN JOIN
THE CHEERING.
FEWER WHITE PEOPLE SHE SAID IS
FABULOUS NEWS.
THEN WE NEED TO PREVENT MINORITY
WHITE RULE.
DO YOU RECOGNIZE THAT PHRASE
>> Kennedy: SOUTH AFRICA,
THAT'S WHAT SHE WANTS.
SOUTH AFRICA.
SHE SAID IT, WE DIDN'T.
BUT WAIT A SECOND, WHAT ABOUT
THE NUMBERS?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THOSE WHITE
PEOPLE NOW MISSING FROM THE
CENSUS?
IT TURNS OUT MANY OF THEM
PERISHED IN THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
AMERICANS MOSTLY FROM RURAL
COMMUNITIES DEAD FROM DRUG
OVERDOSES.
A COLUMNIST FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST"'S CHEERING
THAT, THEIR DEATHS ARE FABULOUS,
SHE SAYS.
IT'S HARD TO KNOW HOW TO RESPOND
TO THAT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO PULL BACK AND
LET PEDRO GONZALES, WE ARE HAPPY
TO HAVE HIM JOIN US NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
YOU WANTED TO WRECK THE
UNITED STATES AND CAUSE ACTUAL
CONFLICT, HE WOULD TALK LIKE JEN
RUBIN.
WHY ARE THEY TALKING THIS WAY?
>> BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT POWER
AND CONTROL AND THE FUNNY THING
ABOUT THE RUBIN NARRATIVE IS
BASICALLY WHITE PEOPLE ARE BEING
MARGINALIZED YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO NOTICE THEM AND NOT ALLOWED
TO TALK ABOUT IT AND IF YOU
DISAGREE WITH THEM BEING
MARGINALIZED, YOU ARE RACIST.
IT'S RACIST OF COURSE BECAUSE
SUPPOSEDLY WHITE PEOPLE ARE THE
VILLAINS OF HUMAN HISTORY.
THE TRUTH IS THE SPECTER OF
WHITE SUPREMACY IS USED TO FUEL
THE GROWTH OF A CORRUPT
POLITICAL ORDER AND THE WHITES
THE VICTIMS IN THE SYSTEM.
YOU LOOK AT THINGS LIKE WAGES
AND LIFE EXPECTANCY, THOSE HAVE
FALLEN FOR THE WHITE WORKING
CLASS WHILE THEY RISEN FOR ALL
OTHER GROUPS.
YOU LOOK AT OUR CULTURE OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, WE
DISADVANTAGED THEM AND WE DO IT
BY LOWERING EXPECTATIONS AND
STANDARDS FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
IT DEATHS RELATED TO SUICIDE AND
AS YOU NOTED DRUG OVERDOSES AND
ALCOHOL RELATED ILLNESSES HAVE
SOARED FOR MIDDLE-AGED WHITE MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE LAST 20 YEARS.
AND PEOPLE LIKE JENNIFER RUBIN
CAN SAY YOU DESERVE IT, I'M
GOING TO SPIT ON YOUR GRADE AND
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO NOTICE OR
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
ALL OF THIS AS A RESULT OF
DELIBERATE POLICY CHOICES.
IT'S ALSO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
PROBLEM.
THE RULING CLASS IN THIS COUNTRY
HAS DECONSTRUCTED IN THE NATION
IT WAS ENTRUSTED TO GOVERN AND
INVITED MILLIONS OF PEOPLE INTO
THIS COUNTRY AND TOLD THEM HE
JUST POINT TO A WHITE PERSON AND
SAY IT'S YOUR FAULT.
WITH PSYCHOTIC BUT HISTORICALLY,
THIS IS WHAT IMPERIAL AND
COLONIAL GOVERNMENTS DO.
THEY ENCOURAGE DIVISION BETWEEN
GROUPS IN OTHER WORDS MAKING
PEOPLE HATE EACH OTHER IS A
POINT.
THE NEOLIBERAL POLITICS OF
RACIAL GRIEVANCES OF DEMOGRAPHIC
DECONSTRUCTION FOR ABOUT
POISONING AND THE MORAL
CHARACTER OF AMERICANS AND
MAKING THEM SO HATEFUL TO EACH
OTHER THAT THEY DON'T NOTICE
PEOPLE LIKE THE UNIT PARTY
ACTIVELY TRYING TO DESTROY THEIR
LIVES.
>> Tucker: WE JUST NEED TO
TALK ABOUT AMERICANS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS HAVE DIED OF OPIOID
ODs AND THE ONLY ONE IN
WASHINGTON WHO NOTICES HIS
GEORGE FLOYD SO HOW DO YOU THINK
AMERICANS FEEL ABOUT THAT IF
YOUR NEPHEW OR SON JUST DIED AT
22 OF AN OPIOID O.D. AND
JENNIFER RUBIN SAID THAT IS
GREAT NEWS, YOU ARE GOING TO GET
SOMETHING HORRIBLE IF YOU KEEP
ACTING THAT WAY, OR IN?
>> IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY
DEHUMANIZING.
YOU ARE COMPLETELY STRIPPING
PEOPLE OF THE THING THAT MAKES
THEM HUMAN AND REDUCING THEM TO
POINTS ON A BOARD.
FEWER WHITE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY LIKE YOU SAID IS A GOOD
THING AND IF YOU ARE A WHITE
PERSON AND YOU HEAR THIS, WHAT
IS YOUR REACTION GOING TO BE?
YOU ARE BASICALLY STOKING --
THERE'S NO WAY TO PUT THIS
NICELY, YOU ARE GINNING UP
RACIAL HATRED BETWEEN DIFFERENT
GROUPS IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
MIGHT OTHERWISE GET ALONG AND
YOU'RE DOING IT FOR EITHER
POLITICAL OR IDEOLOGICAL
REASONS.
NOT SURE WHICH IS WORSE.
WHETHER YOU REALLY BELIEVE IN
OUT STUFF FORWARDS MEANS TO AN
END.
IN EITHER CASE, IF YOU WANT TO
DESTROY A SOCIETY, THIS IS HOW
YOU DO IT.
>> Tucker: AND THEY ARE GOING
TO BE PEOPLE SUPER RADICAL AS
WELL, NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.